the right tries to maintain this this
idea that there's a constitution and
that we have rights and these things are
being upheld but when every major
institution is corrupt you just got a
group of conservatives who are like
there's a constitution as long as it
stands and it's like bro you live in the
past
like hollywood schools like the crt and
school stuff is a perfect example
absolute corruption the media then lies
to cover up the extreme stuff they're
pulling off let me actually let me let
me pull up the story right here
florida shares examples of critical race
theory in banned textbooks what me
racist more than two million people have
tested their racial prejudice reads one
textbook's math problem
so florida got rid of a bunch of math
books because they said they had racial
critical race theory indoctrination in
them
now
prominent progressives and leftists are
saying the right is banning math because
they don't want people to learn math
what you actually see in these books is
it says things like
the bar graph shows the the differences
among age groups on the implicit
association test that measure measures
levels of racial prejudice higher scores
indicate a stronger bias
what does that have to do with math why
are they showing these graphs adding and
subtracting polynomials what me racist
more than two million people have tested
their racial prejudice online using a
version of the implicit
uh association test many groups average
scores fall between slight and moderate
bias that's in a math book when they
when they when they remove those books
from school
democrats corporate press and
progressive activists make up insane
lies yeah but everybody i mean it's all
propaganda you have propaganda on both
sides and i mean this is a math book
though this is like a a grade school
math book
okay
where is that book is it all over
america is it in all the schools now
florida state the textbooks have gotten
pretty cool
okay so florida is one of 50 states okay
i think you know these happen
all over the place like virginia for
example okay but but there's a little
bit of broad sweeping generalization
here i mean i have more
faith in
in our
world than
believing that all this stuff is going
to stick some of it's going to buff out
tim
well yeah because people have started to
stand up and say no yeah but it seems
like it's it's it's mostly uh only in
florida right so so disney comes out and
what's happening in florida if you're
not familiar is they passed a bill
called the parental rights and education
bill which
grants parents the right to know i know
now what happens immediately is don't
say gay but the bill nowhere in any way
has anything to do with that right the
bill is just you know certain sex ed
concepts for you know for kindergarten
to third grade not allowed and the
teachers can't keep secrets from the
parents on physical mental or medical
issues parents have a right to know
what's in their curriculum
the media comes out and says don't say
gay that's not true
the only people fighting back against
this are for the most part in florida we
did see after this i think tex texas uh
idaho mississippi we're starting to see
statewide hyperpolarization to push back
but it's really polarizing so a better
example is probably abortion where
oklahoma i think outright banned
abortion just literally banned it unless
it's for the life of the mother and
colorado now allows abortion up to the
point of birth meaning a fully developed
nine-month-old baby can be too extreme
yeah right yeah and and so this is
what's happening in in this country so
it's not that it's buffing out it's that
the the lines that there's two distinct
cultures that have emerged i know but
that for right now and this is what
happens historically and everything
doesn't everything is it's not
everything moves you know it doesn't
stay in the same place and
having
conversations and arguments and
providing a forum for
uh debate is what we have to keep going
so the
the the left as i guess it would be
colloquially described won't come on a
show like this
that's why i came on the show who is the
left so uh typical typically uh there is
left is a reference to tribal spheres of
influence as is right it doesn't really
mean much of anything i just mean who
are like who have you asked well no we
can't get into that i i
well so there's a lot of people yeah
it's funny you say that because recently
there have been a couple of invitations
right absolutely so one of the most
notable is one of the biggest uh
political streamers for the left is
hassan [ __ ] who i've repeatedly invited
on the show but he's always got a
different excuse the first time it was
you know i said i tweeted out we we
invite these people on the show they
always say yes and then ghost us
and then hassan tweets out i'll come on
your show i said we will pay for
everything we'll get you a hotel we'll
bring you out in style then he privately
messages me saying no i'm scared to
covet i won't do it.
now he's saying i'm not i'm not going to
travel to your show i'm too busy we
recently had another guy that i was uh
uh
that was arguing and posting outright
lies
and it's just insane that these people
i'll tell you i'll tell you how crazy it
is
i'm holding up a pen where you can see
it yeah i'm not holding a pen
that's what they do the washington post
published the private address of someone
on twitter you can see it and they're
going no they didn't and you're like why
am i even talking to you if you're just
going to say something so you just have
to find other people there's no other
people there have to be other people
have you been did you watch the um
the french you know macron and uh le pen
okay now they were given this is this is
the way we should debate things they're
each given like i don't know what it is
like an hour and a half
and there's no like you know you have 30
seconds to answer this question and they
actually they insult each other they
talk to each other but they have enough
time
to actually have a conversation so this
is which is a debate which is instead of
a sound bite here and there yeah so we
that that's why we have this you know
two and a half hour long show
now shout out to vosh he's a he's a
leftist socialist a youtuber who a lot
of people on the right hate especially
because of his his views on children and
adult content for children
but he came on the show twice and uh
that's that's that's pretty much uh
there's also jen pearlman shout out to
jen she's a progressive and she's come
on the show we've had great
conversations but this this this guy who
was recently arguing that something that
literally happened didn't messaging me
saying he'll come on the show i say here
email us so we can set it up and then he
ghosts us it's just it's a recurring
world that's cowardly i think what it is
is like you're so
we talked earlier before the show about
like are we inheriting you know the tail
end of the
uh counterculture progressive movement
that you guys initiated in the late 60s
and like i think to a certain extent
what we're talking about here when you
say what is the left i mean to a certain
extent it's it it has become orthodoxy
of this kind of like monolithic you know
mainstream idea of what it is to be a
good person to be a moral virtuous
person and so anybody who engages with
the tim poole is stepping outside of
that orthodoxy and and nobody wants to
be that person who you know steps
outside of where everybody is you know
thinking right and doing but i did and a
lot of my old friends won't talk to me
or don't talk to me they unfollow me and
stuff because it's like ian's a part of
the fascist movement of the united
states where i'm like yo the federal
reserve shout out to everyone in the
chat that loves that one is fascist i'm
trying to expose that stuff
and we
and uh
like the establishment i guess we call
it the establishment they just outright
make things up right
i think that left and right is a
communist i mean it goes back to the
french revolution where people sat on
the left they were the revolutionaries
people sat on the right they were the
loyalists and so it really literally
comes from they called themselves the
left and the right of the aisle
mao talked a lot about the rightists and
he persecuted the rightists in the
cultural revolution of china and so i
think that somehow they've wormed that
into our modern discourse to get us to
divide each other
i i look at uh uh we just had the mask
singer do you guys see this
uh rudy giuliani turned out to have been
the mask singer and who was the guy
yeah there's that show
there's a show called masked singer
where someone wears a costume and sings
okay and then they got to guess who it
was
turns out the mask comes off
rudy giuliani he's got a beautiful voice
turns out well so uh i think it was ken
jong was that his name
oh yeah he walks off stage
i thought about that because people have
said that twitter isn't real life for a
long time that social media isn't real
life i think the real issue is that
twitter has always been real life but
for a younger generation what i see
happening now is when you look at cable
tv cnn msnbc and fox news their viewers
are overwhelmingly over 56 years old
so
all of this stuff is happening
it is it is worse than i've ever seen it
granted i'm only 36
and i feel like the older generation
doesn't understand how bad it is because
they're not actually in the same culture
as the rest of us that's possible that's
quite possible
so for you know richie to experience
things on the ground
i'll give you
one of my favorite examples of the the
hyper polarization is a man named daryl
davis
he's a he's an old black jazz musician
he thought to himself one day how could
someone hate me if they never met me so
he went to a clan rally met some old
klansmen
started talking to him and he said sure
enough they were racist but after a few
weeks to a few months these guys started
taking off their robes and saying i was
completely wrong they were like the
things they say about black people does
not represent my good friend daryl he
told one story about how he met this
clansman who was high-ranking
and he had his he he was just he would
have had this dream to see this famous
rock and roll car in a museum or
something like that and daryl's like oh
i can get you in there and he was like
get out of here and then here he is this
racist guy having his dream come true
granted to him by by a black man and
these people were like all of a sudden
like this racist stuff is wrong
so this is daryl davis we booked him uh
he's incredible i'm a huge fan how old
is he uh you can find out i'm not sure
he's gonna be here actually soon and um
we booked him for an event to headline
because the event was about essentially
civil libertarianism it was called
ending violence racism and
authoritarianism we wanted people to be
like we want to get rid of this stuff
far left extremists showed up and
threatened to burn down the theater so
the theater canceled our contract within
i think it was like three weeks of the
event we were forced to move the event
to a casino with half the capacity
because the casino had the security and
they were willing to do it another venue
nearby told us we love what you're doing
but we will have our venue burned down
if we host this conversation the
protesters showed up to the after party
and daryl davis having de-radicalized
over 200 klansmen said i'm gonna go talk
to these guys and see what's up and yet
they did they screamed at him and
wouldn't let him say one word he was so
shocked he wrote he wrote this this post
on facebook where he said i can't
believe it i've never experienced
anything like this
what is what is going on with these
people and ended up going massively
viral because the current state of
politics in this country is the younger
left generation we call it the left
whatever we call it group a group b
whatever
they are unwilling to compromise
unwilling to talk they are uh angry
chaotic and destructive
so uh for example the guy who said the
washington post never posted a private
address and everyone's showing the image
of them doing it and he's like no they
didn't
these are people who don't care about
what's true they know that they can say
it and their people go gullible enough
to just believe it and that gives them
power
so you have uh it was the late david
graber who said elements of the left
have adopted the fascistic tenet there
is no truth but power and this guy was
called the anarchist anthropologist he
was one of the progenitors of occupy
wall street
he uh later in his life he said i'm
watching the left embrace fascistic
tenets
and that's and that's where we are now
where
uh the corporate press will outright
make something up their allies and
nonprofits will make things up the whole
insurrection narrative all of this stuff
are outright lies my favorite example in
this capacity is that in january i said
it's going to be very difficult to
convict someone of trespassing at the
capitol when the police opened the doors
for them
the young turks then make up a lie that
i said people who are violent shouldn't
be charged because there were no signs
right and it works for their audience i
invite them on the show i say we'll
cover all your costs we've known each
other for years they laugh and they say
of course not we don't care we don't
actually care about this stuff
daryl davis is 64 years old by the way
she's turned 64 in march happy birthday
yeah i think that's a that's a good
point though tim is like that's it's
like a
lack of any initiative to engage with
the other side and i'm wondering like
back in the 60s and 70s like
you know somebody who was like uh bible
thumping you know whatever world war ii
veteran who had the white picket fence
and then their kid went off to vietnam
and they were all for you know were you
not not willing to engage with somebody
like that like was it you know if you're
this then i won't even talk to you i
think
you know when
earlier we talked about it being more
generational
than
partisan
because we were filled with hope about
the fact that we could make a change we
could make a difference we could end the
war
and
if it might have been naive but that's
how we united
and we disagreed i mean richard nixon
was the enemy
because he perpetuated the war
and
uh but would you talk to a nixon
supporter like because i think that's i
tried to talk to my father about it well
the feminists today are pro-war
what are you that's a broad
generalization but it's true what do you
mean i'm a feminist i'm not pro-war
right so my generation's feminists are
pro-war
but we've got all of them well i mean
i never i'm i didn't say absolutely i'm
saying if you were to take 10 modern
feminists right now and ask them if they
wanted intervention in ukraine they'd
say yes
that's probably fair point absolutely
donald trump uh got us the abraham
accords i'm so confused
about everything there's like second
third wave feminism from 1994 there's
fourth wave feminism from 2010 so you
got to be specific well i'll put it this
way i'll put it this way either tacitly
or or or directly pro-war for our
generations feminists right the people
who would wear those pink hats right now
are the ones with the ukraine flags and
their bios and they're and they're the
ones that i don't think that's
absolutely true mine
uh pink cats right so i'm not saying
absolutely i'm saying you know
why if you take ten of these people and
ask them do you think the u.s should be
involved in the ukraine russia war
they'll say yes
i think chris chris coons the democratic
senator said it's time for u.s boots on
the ground yeah i mean it's a paradigm
shift it's a paradigm shift right there
are still plenty of those hippies but
granola folks those are the they're also
like anti-vaxx a lot but
but take a look at this point uh with
donald trump no new wars
for the first time in my life a
president did not start a war in fact
with uh with kushner's guidance we got
the abraham accords which brought
economic stability between countries
like uh saudi arabia or uh or just
countries
with israel so now planes are allowed to
fly over israel tremendous piece there
was also i think um what else was it was
it bosnia he had that uh other peace
agreement he was withdrawing our troops
from afghanistan he was getting our
troops out of syria he was uh uh
generally
making moves to end war and that's one
of the reasons i did not vote for him in
2016 but i did in 2020 because he's had
a timeline for the withdrawal from
afghanistan but
today's feminists of my generation
opposed that
and they voted for joe biden who was
part of an administration that caused i
think seven wars started seven wars
so whether tacitly or directly and
testedly i say
you look at donald trump's body of work
as an activist and you say i'd rather
vote for the guy who starts war as
opposed to the guy who ends them they're
pro-war that's tacit now the direct
stuff is the people who right now are
aligning with democrats saying they want
intervention in ukraine malcolm nance i
mean he's an mbs msnbc host went to to
ukraine he's 60 years old and he's got a
fake picture of himself holding a gun
and tactical gear these people are
outright pro-war well i think that they
think if we go in we'll end the war
which is why that's it's not a uni
united states uh issue yeah but neither
was world war ii
talking about a real threat we're
talking about paris it's a regional
conflict so was world war ii if vladimir
putin invades poland nato can intervene
ukraine is not a nato country it is not
an eu country and they have a con
conflict with russia and you have
democrats and the the you know our
generations left saying intervention war
weapons etc i mean it's absolutely
insane that the arguments i'm hearing
from progressives are that we should
have a no-fly zone which is a
declaration of war on russia yeah i
think they're misguided but a lot of
them are it's like it's almost as if i
mean that is kind of embedded in exactly
what you said is kind of the substance
of a paradigm shift which is like it
used to be the right that was always
reactionary and always responding from
what the left did and you know whatever
they do we have to oppose because we
need to retain our traditions and values
but now it's like
it's almost like once donald trump took
control of the republican party it's
like every the left has to react to
everything that they do and say no
that's got to be but it was trump and
bernie yeah trump and bernie was a
generational
flip that just shocked the whole system
now bernie lost uh and you know hillary
won that primary donald trump stormed
his way into the republican party and
brought with him a wave of
you know
very much a shift from the traditional
conservative
model to a more left economic what about
north korea and the fact that he was
palsy whales he was that's fantastic i
nearly cried when um when he was
negotiating peace my my
great-grandfather is from what would now
be called north korea and the prospect
of de-escalation was was was fascinating
and trump was negotiating that donald
trump crossed into north korean
territory with no security
that was one of the most profound plus
like anti-war moments of my life we've
been palsy wealthy with the saudi
arabians for generations and nobody's
called that into question because he's
not one of those but just just think
about this donald trump crossed into
north korea with no security and walked
peacefully up with kim jong-un and i was
just my jaw hit the floor i was like
they could have snatched him up they
could have grabbed him and said now you
give us what we want they shook his hand
he walked back they smiled and waved and
he left and i said that is leadership
donald trump risked his life now i get
it the threat is backed by we have
nuclear bombs but we are not going to
mutually assure destruction they always
say no donald trump i couldn't believe
he did that the the guy they claim is
the most selfish and insane guy in the
world just risked his life for what
point i was just like it would it would
be a profound moment for me to hear that
the korean peninsula had been reunited
and donald trump made tremendous steps
in that direction i i don't think it was
perfect i think kim jong-un is a bad guy
i think they they took advantage of
trump in many ways but that was
incredible
i'm looking at uh just as clarification
it looks like bosnians wasn't involved
in the pc but it was it was uh serbia
and kosovo oh sorry right yeah yeah yep
yeah and these peace deals yeah i do
have a lot of issues with trump he
wasn't definitely wasn't perfect but
it's nice to to see somebody that's not
part of the war machine but look at the
people who came out and were like oh the
obama administration the ones who signed
the indefinite detention provisions in
the in the national defense
authorization act barack obama who
authorized extrajudicial assassinations
of american citizens and they were like
i would rather have that guy his vice
president than donald trump who signed
peace agreements
and and and fought and worked towards
ending conflict internationally no new
wars and they voted for joe biden i just
the left is is profoundly pro-war when
do you think that happened was it like
so you just mentioned bosnia like ma
during the bosnia war the american
public right they were pretty for
intervention right like that was clinton
is that when it flipped when the left
wing started to become pro war
like because you were anti-war you were
progressive in the 60s
how did that change you know how like
why is it 2008
you think it was georgie george w bush i
remember marching in protests over the
war in iraq and i was a teenager so i
knew very little for the most part about
what was going on other than why are we
invading this war over weapons of mass
destruction all that stuff and we were
told it wasn't true people were marching
with signs saying george w bush was
hitler and all that and i was mostly
just kind of like yeah punk rock
screw the system george w bush is bad
and uh boy was it a cold splash of water
when we did it
barack obama got elected
and then i said all right well the first
thing obama did one of the first orders
he signed was bombing a village full of
women and children and i said guys guys
hey let's keep this protest going now
we're good and they all disappeared all
these anti-war protesters were gone
i think what happened was
it was this is the the emergence of
overt tribalism around the same time
facebook and twitter and these other
social networks that are emerging and
people developed tribal identities which
is i support barack obama that's who i
am i don't care what he does and for me
i was kind of like i think killing
children is bad so what was the what are
you referring to i'm not sure i remember
barack obama yeah barack obama
authorized a drone strike on a civilian
restaurant in yemen killing a 16 year
old american citizen named abdulrahman
al-awlaki
and the response from the white house
when asked about it was oops we were
trying to kill a different terrorist by
bombing a civilian restaurant just so
turns out though anwar al-awlaki his dad
was an american citizen who was also
killed in an extrajudicial assassination
signed off by obama and to me it sounded
like obama was sending a signal we will
kill your children that's just my
opinion all that matters is i won't
speculate in the absence of evidence the
solution which makes the least amount of
assumptions tends to be correct barack
obama authorized the assassination of an
american citizen by bombing a civilian
cafe and people voted for him again i
didn't and people voted for his vp over
donald trump i wrote a form twice so
here you have a guy who is quite
literally killing not only children in
these countries under the obama
administration in order to get around
the fact that it was being reported they
were executing civilians by drone they
said
if the male is over 18 we don't care
what they're doing carrying water
harvesting crops raising goats their
enemy combatants because their military
age
when our good friend luke rudkowski
confronted the administration on the
execution of the american citizen
i can't remember the guy's name was
charlie gibbs he said he should have had
a better father that was their attitude
and so i sit here i watch all of this
stuff and then i say i have always
maintained that i think this is
disgusting since the george w bush era i
have learned my lesson with voting for
people like obama when donald trump came
around hillary clinton i laughed you
think i'm voting for trump nice try
hillary clinton she's a warmonger to
beat out all war mongers she didn't get
my vote either and then in donald
trump's presidency we saw a return of
american manufacturing we saw a three
billion dollar investment in michigan we
saw a challenging of the racist policies
coming out of critical race theory and
we saw no new wars we saw historic peace
agreements and attempts at other
historic peace agreements and i said i
gotta vote for this guy he needs another
term thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there